do you think that there's a usefulness
in having a nemesis to motivate you
talking about some of the situations
that you've been through not
particularly those ones exactly but
i try to avoid making enemies of people
or groups or ideas or whatever yes don't
make unnecessary enemies but
there is an extra level of fire that
gets lit underneath you when you're
going up against someone and i miss it
sometimes there's a price that you pay
for peace
yeah well then you just have to look at
yourself harder and find the nemesis
because it's there all the time
right i mean there's always parts of
yourself that you can overcome
and so that's william james moral
equivalent to war essentially now if you
need something to grapple with
you probably do
you can find that you just look inside
you'll find something to grapple with
you know inadequacy weakness
susceptibility to temptation narcissism
pride
envy revenge resentment frustration lack
of faith all of that
that that'll keep you occupied if you
really grapple with it and yeah i mean
that's an ancient theological question
you know what's up with the devil
why why is that why does the possibility
of evil exist why is there an eternal
adversary you see that reflected in cain
and abel right at the beginning of the
genesis stories essentially the first
two human beings are
good set against an adversary and that's
that's what opens history that story you
think well why would god construct such
a
why would god construct a reality where
an adversary exists and maybe it's
because all things considered a world
with an adversary is a better world just
like a garden with a snake and it is a
better garden
these things aren't easy to understand
no no snake no necessity to contend with
snakes
so why be awake at all
no adversary no challenge why be
challenged because maybe you're better
for the challenge
and maybe that's the challenge to see if
you can be better for the challenge but
that should be internal well
fundamentally well if it isn't you'll
find it externally because you'll
demonize someone to turn them into satan
so that you can find an adversary and
then that's very unfortunate for you and
for them
that's just not as big a battle it's
like
you you battle with someone external
who's malevolent let's say or you think
they are and usually you've got that
mostly wrong but not always
but if the battle is inside which is
where it's supposed to be
most fundamentally then
well then it's the ultimate it is the
ultimate challenge and that's the
infinite game
the external one battle between good and
evil on a playing field of chaos and
order that's the eternal game
and you know you can play that out in
the external world but
part of what
the religious enterprise up is about
and the christians have really
contributed to this
is the notion that that sacred battle is
fundamentally spiritual which is to say
in some sense fundamentally
psychological it's to be
it's to be fought on the battleground of
the soul
internally it's a subjective issue how
do you defeat evil
you defeat the evil in your own heart
that's that is how you do it
and so if that's all being acted out
for you in the world well you you've
misplaced satan that's a good way of
thinking about it this is another
weakness i think of the atheistic
position because
you can it's pretty hard it's an easy in
some sense to dispense with belief in
the highest good but it's not so easy to
dispense with belief in evil
so that's a big problem so then where do
you localize it and you can find
evidence of it everywhere certainly in
institutions i mean that's the whole
systemic racism corrupt patriarchy
narrative is that satan is to be found
at the core of our institutions and to
some degree
that's true
because everything we do is corrupt to
some degree
and so then do you fight it
sociologically you're the good person
and
the the institution is
satan
so you're so good are you
you're so sure of that are you
you've got everything in order or do you
and you might say well you have to have
everything in order before you
fight evil on the sociological front and
the answer is well no because you're
never going to have everything in order
but
you still shouldn't put the cart before
the horse
it's really it's a spiritual battle and
it's taken people thousands and
thousands of years to figure this out
now first of all it was the snake
what's what's evil what's malevolent the
predatory reptile fair enough man i mean
we've been fighting with predatory
reptiles for 60 million years as mammals
60 million years
so it's a good first pass approximation
it's the snake the poisonous snake the
external enemy the predator
well what about the predator and other
people
oh yeah that's even worse man it's like
how pretty predators are one thing but
predatory people other tribes man
they're brutal they're brutal oh
well what about your predatory friend
oh that's pretty bad too the friend who
stabs you in the back the person who
betrays you judas god maybe that's the
ultimate snake it's like well how about
when you betray yourself
oh yeah
so you want to see there's this
association that's very strange that
occurred in the development of christian
thought between the snake and the garden
of eden and satan there's no indication
in the original story that the snake has
anything to do with the lord of all evil
it's a very weird
conclusion that's been drawn it's almost
extra biblical because there's almost no
mention of satan in the bible at all
much less any direct connection between
the serpent and satan it's a very very
strange idea but it's part of this
psychologization of evil
like what's the ultimate predator
what's the ultimate predator
what's the enemy you harbor
in your own heart who hates you
that's the ultimate predator
oh and when there's these images of mary
uh
with her head in the stars and baby in
her arms and her foot on a snake it's
like well
that's the eternal feminine her head's
in the stars because she's oriented
towards the highest good and she's
protecting her infant from predators
that could be
an actual predator but that has been the
case throughout not just human history
but mammalian history could be
other people who are predators
could be men who are predators
could be her
who's a predator
the devouring mother
it's like well
what's what's the ultimate locale of
genuine evil well the
highest religious answer is that's in
you
that's the proper place to battle it out
and
i think that's true
i think that's lit it's literally and
metaphorically true and i i was
convinced of that in part because of
solzhenitsyn's writings because
solzhenitsyn identified the totalitarian
state with the
willingness of
the subjects of that state the subjects
and the perpetrators at the same time
to live by lies
note no la no totalitarian state if
people don't lie
every time you lie in support of the
totalitarian state then you're the
perpetrator
and that's a psychological issue it's
like you're gonna lie to get along or
not
say well what does it matter
i'll go along with it it's okay
we'll see how it matters
because it matters
and that's all psychodrama as far as i'm
concerned
fundamentally when it's properly
you've got plenty of problems to take
care of on your own front
and that's where you should concentrate
your efforts what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace